okay so i guess we'll go ahead and get
started now
my name is richard gass i'm a physicist
at the
university of cincinnati and um i want
to tell you about some
home physics labs that you can do using
mathematica in your phone
okay so i'm going to skip the
abstract because you can all read the
abstract
um okay and uh
sort of go right into the uh meat of
things okay
so with kovid labs of course
pose a special challenge it's very
difficult
or impossible to social distance in labs
and we of course have to plan for the
worst case which is that the university
could close completely
or we could undergo another lockdown
so there are possible solutions all of
which have
pluses and minuses so you can
of course try to social distance maybe
in multiple rooms or with a subset of
the students
okay you could use simulated labs
the downside of that is that you don't
have real data in a simulated lab
although it can be very valuable
it doesn't teach the students everything
that a real lab
does you could have students do
computational labs
once again that's not really a lab
although in the course that i'm going to
talk about we do
do a number of computational labs
you can have students do real data use
real data from
say nasa or european space agency ligo
and so on
that might not fit your existing
curriculum very well or they could do
citizen science projects okay or you
could have students do
home labs or projects which is the
subject of this talk
in our advanced lab taken by the seniors
are
our senior majors we're currently using
a mix of these approaches
but i teach a course called intermediate
physics
okay and i also have responsibility
for historical reasons for a first-year
majors lab
and these are relatively small courses
which is to say they have
30 to 40 students in them the
intermediate physics lab is the course
i'm really going to talk about
it's required of all our second year
majors
it's a five credit course with four
lectures a week plus a
lab that is attached to the course and
it's combined
so you get a single grade okay and the
the focus of the first semester is waves
and vibrations with a little special
relativity thrown in at the end
and then the second semester we do
special relativity and
quantum mechanics okay
and i was trying to think of what i
could do for the labs
and there's a old berkeley series
book on waves by frank crawford which
has
home experiments so i thought well maybe
i can just
kind of swipe those okay
but the focus of those is somewhat
different because they're to
support a you know a
course that has a real physical
in-person lab
in it and it's a bit dated my students
for instance don't have access to
turntables and so on
but what they all do have is a
smartphone
and they all have a laptop because we
require them to have a laptop
and they all have mathematical on their
laptop because
we have a university-wide site license
so although it is not
free for them that
central i.t people charge them for that
it's still relatively inexpensive
so we require our majors all to have
mathematica
okay so you can use the data
from both sensors and video in the smart
phone
and and there are various apps such as
physics toolbox or firefox which give
direct access to the senate to the
sensor data
and these run on both android and ios
and that
apps are free okay so the advantage to
this is that you get real experiments
with real data
i'll show you that the data quality can
be extremely high
okay it's as is always the case with
real data it's richer than
than stimulated data they're you know
things that you don't quite understand
about real data always
the disadvantages are that you have to
redo your entire
let lab curriculum write
new lab write-ups for all these labs so
it's a lot of work
we put together student kits that we
ship to our students
because i couldn't depend on them
necessarily having any particular item
and i had to plan for the case where
the county might start to be locked down
again
and it wouldn't be easy for them to get
various pieces of equipment
okay and then at home experiments are
hard there's no ta there
sits you know sitting in front of you
the
they do have a virtual they do have a ta
over zoom
but uh you know the experiments aren't
set up with the equipment collected for
you and so on
so i worry about students getting
frustrated it's worked okay so far
but we're not through the semester yet
and i worry about maintaining student
engagement
on a remote experiment and there may be
issues that
just haven't cropped up yet but i want
to give you four examples
okay one of them is a simple pendulum
okay
one of them is a helmholtz resonator and
then
the two richest ones are a coupled
oscillator
and waves on a string and these all fit
well
into the curriculum for me because
this is a course on waves and vibrations
starting with simple harmonic motion
and moving on to waves in a continuous
medium and traveling waves and
and so on
so we start we started the semester with
a
session that was basically get to know
one another
do you have mathematica installed on
your laptop does it work and so on
and then the first lab they did was a
simple pendulum lab
and so the idea behind this and most of
these labs is
that we will leverage the ability of
your smartphone
to take really high quality data with
the
ability of mathematica to
do automatic feature tracking so
here's the uh my home setup
you'll see it's just a uh it's
actually a large washer hung from a
weight and a door hanger
with a background behind it and a couple
of tape marks
okay and these tape marks
you won't really see here but they've
got 10 centimeter marks on them
so that i can convert distances in a
picture to actual physical distances
so we ship them door hangers
we ship them washers string masking tape
marking pens and perhaps most critically
tripods that would hold their
smartphone so they just pull the
pendulum back
at a small angle okay and
film the motion okay
we import the movie into mathematica and
we use video extract
frames to extract
all the frames okay and if necessary
then image rotate to rotate the images
if you didn't have your smartphone in
the proper orientation
i didn't so i had to rotate them by
pi over two and then they click
on okay there should be a picture
here they click on the pendulum bob here
and there's a red tracking dot that i
put here and they click
on that with the coordinate tool okay
from the drawing tools to extract the
coordinates of that
which they then feed to
image feature track okay so rotated
images these are the
list of properly rotated images from
their movie
and here we have the
the coordinates of the object they want
to track okay
and so they track that throughout their
video frame
throughout their right list of
frames and then for this lab they also
need to measure
the local acceleration of gravity so
they do that
using their uh their phone and
the firefox app which allows them to
export that acceleration as a
xls file which they then import into
mathematica
and uh
okay i'll show you those results in a
moment one thing we hadn't anticipated
really was that some students had
dropped their phone so often
that their sensor no longer worked very
well
so there were a couple students we had
to
ship data to for measuring small g
okay so once they have the
feature tracked using image feature
track right
and now they have mathematica which is a
really powerful tool of course for
analysis
so here i'm showing you a plot of the
horizontal displacement from equilibrium
this has been now converted into
physical distances
i shot this video at 30 frames a second
there's no need to be
faster for this experiment i'll show you
an experiment later where there is
and you can see it's really high quality
data there's
a little scatter but really not very
much at all
the fit to the data is
is quite good and
of course they can use the fit
parameters to determine an
error here in the in the frequency
they need to measure g of course as a
function of time because they want to
compare
their measured frequency to the
experimental frequent
frequency so they get some scatter here
from using their
sensor right they can take the mean of
that look at the standard deviation
right i mean this is all really easy to
do in mathematica
and also introduces them to you know
ideas of statistical uncertainty and so
forth
um these are second year students so in
theory they knew
some of this from first year but in
practice
that's been long forgotten and so they
can now compare
you know and here we're using the new
well relatively new
air bar capabilities of mathematica
they can compare their theory to
experiment and you'll notice
right right the the scale here
so they've actually made a very precise
quite precise measurement of the period
of the
pendulum the theoretical error is much
larger than the
experiment because this error is
dominated by the ability to measure the
length of the string to the center of
mass
of their
the nut that they are using as a
pendulum bob
uh we shipped them uh cheap tape
measures
as well and and their home experiment
kit
so the next experiment i wanted to well
so what happens then in the curriculum
is that we actually have a two week
pause in physical
experiments we do two weeks of
of linear algebra both by hand
and and in mathematica
their linear algebra tends to be a
little weak okay
so the next experiment is uh then a
helmholtz resonator
um thinking about now air is a spring
um and so this is these
sort of the easiest experiment uh they
need a bottle
and a ruler a measuring cup and a
smartphone
so you blow across the bottle you use
your smartphone app to record the
frequencies
which you then import in which you
export as an xls
file import that into mathematica
then add water to the bottle to change
the volume
okay and you can plot
the theoretical value for the frequency
of a helmholtz resonator
okay as a function of the
right of the volume of your bottle
you can see here that the experimental
points
mostly lie below the theoretical points
and that's because this model is only a
kind of approximation
you've got this effective length of the
neck which tells you
really how much how big the plug of area
is that you push down when you blow
across it and this is kind of empirical
and so it's typical that you don't
fit the theory exactly but this allows
them to
to think about what happens when your
theoretical model isn't
exactly perfect either
okay and this is an experiment that
they're currently
finishing up and then next week they'll
start
a coupled oscillator experiment okay
this experiment turns out to be
extraordinarily rich
actually richer than i'd originally
realized
and so you can see my setup at home
i've got two springs and two masses you
can see
just kind of barely a couple of small
blue
tracking dots
here in general small dots work better
than larger dots for
video tracking you can see that i did a
actually exceptionally poor job here of
orienting my dot
okay but nevertheless
image feature track is able to
to track this so i filmed this
once again at about 30 frame well not
about at 30 frames a second
um and i followed the oscillators for
about
40 seconds i believe um
you know brought the images into
mathematica rotated them to
fix the fact that i didn't have my
smartphone clamped at
the right angle here we feature track
two objects
and the objects for feature tracking are
these two dots here feature image
feature track does a
amazingly good job provided you don't
have
motion blur and provided the object
never leaves the frame
i haven't been able to get it really to
reacquire an
object that leaves the frame and then
comes back
and motion blur will kill the
feature tracking as well okay but
okay here i've tracked
right um right at
1369 frames so of course there's no way
you could do this by hand
this is really one of the strengths of
automated feature tracking in
mathematica
and you'll see i've been able to track
both the vertical and horizontal motion
of both masses
m1 is the top mass and m2 is the bottom
mass okay
if you look at the scale you'll see that
the motion
the horizontal motion of these two
masses is less than the
vertical motion but
okay in the case of the bottom one not
that much less
and this is just because i could never
really
pull the bottom mass down right
completely vertically there was always
some little
horizontal displacement
and so what i really have is not an
object with two normal modes but an
object with four normal modes because
they're going to be
essentially spring modes from the
oscillation up and down
and also some pendulum modes from the
horizontal oscillation okay
and we could take this data
and take the fourier transform of that
data
okay and pick out the frequencies
and i've done that here
okay so uh this is for
uh the
this is for m1 this is the vertical
motion
right of the top mass but you get
essentially the same thing although the
relative strengths of the amplitudes are
different
if you look at either the horizontal
motion or the motion of the other mass
you'll see there are four peaks here
corresponding to the four normal modes
i've listed the angular frequencies here
and we can identify from the theory um
these modes that this one is really
corresponding to the low frequencies
spring mode then we have a low frequency
pendulum mode which for my setup happens
to lie
very close to the spring mode
there's a high frequency pendulum mode
and a high frequency spring mode
okay
strictly speaking these the spring and
the pendulum modes don't really decouple
except that in this small
small motion limit they do
and we can then compute from theory
right because they do a first part of
this experiment they measure the spring
constant
we also ship them small digital scales
those are cheap so they can measure the
masses and so on
and we've talked about normal modes and
oscillations of these sorts of systems
in lecture right so there's a theory
section where they compute these things
you can see that the agreement between
theory and experiment here
is really good
and i mean i'm i'm just
really impressed by the ability of
cell phones and feature tracking to uh
to take
really high quality data so the last
experiment i want to talk about
is waves on an elastic string one of the
things that we've just started in
lecture
we haven't gotten there in lab yet um is
right uh waves in a continuous medium
okay so uh we shipped them
uh some elastic string okay
and here you see my setup um in the
beginning i was really worried about
providing a uniform background
it turns out that feature image feature
track really
is pretty good if the background isn't
uniform but
and so i just took this and i stretch
the string
and i put these uh you know red marks
here with a red marker
um and you can see some and then i took
the string and i pulled it down
okay and let it go now this gets filmed
at
the fastest rate your smartphone will do
which in my case is 248 frames a second
uh and this early motion here image
feature track actually
fails to track because there is still
it's a little hard to see here but
there's still too much motion blur
okay so it loses the
the red dots but if
you wait a little while and just uh trim
your video
until that some of that motion blur
disappears it will
track okay and so here what i'm showing
you um
okay i track a little over 3000 frames
okay uh with uh
you know the ends plus uh nine data
points
uh from these uh red dots so we're
accumulating over 30 000
pieces of data and here i'm showing you
the transverse displacement
at a fixed point on this on the
string one of the red marks that's close
to the center
the insert here shows you this short
time motion
see it's pretty nice and periodic okay
but there are a couple of
and right i can now extract that motion
from all the dots
and plot that as a function of time it
looks like what a damped elastic string
should look like
and then of course i can use some
fourier analysis
to fish out the uh
the string frequencies um
and i've done this two ways i've
extracted a string
the frequency from the early time data
just by fitting it okay and i've
extracted them
with a fourier transform and with the
fourier transform we see actually that
we can see two modes here
the others have decayed away
[Music]
okay but the fundamental mode here
and then at almost exactly twice that
we see small amplitude of a second mode
that got excited when i pulled the
string down
so with a smartphone and
image feature track you can really
extract
very high quality rich data from
quite complicated physical systems and i
actually think that
when we return to you know physical labs
we will want to rethink some of them
and ask you know what can we do using
the ability to track many frames of
video
and high quality video from a smartphone
to do interesting physics experiments
and uh
for those that are interested i've just
listed
um you know what we sent them for these
experiments
we needed to keep it cheap because right
our universities in financial straits
due to covid
but i've left a little time for
questions so
i'd be more than happy to answer
any questions you might have
okay and um i believe uh brandon can
unmute you too if you wish to ask a uh
a question by by talking rather than
typing
okay so any questions at all um we have
one question
in the past we'll check yes
uh
uh i'm bringing that up now so
uh but i don't see uh here we go it's
just a little slow loading
uh
uh oh
uh oh yeah so jose wants uh wants uh
comment on the error analysis
um yeah so um
so our students are terrible at error
analysis
which i think
you know most students are so i thought
one thing that i would take advantage
of here is the advantage to really
do a little more error analysis than
we normally do and
so what i uh
there's a early discussion there's a
separate error analysis notebook
where we make them do the error analysis
really by hand
okay and then we make heavy use
of a round okay to propagate errors
and uh we make you know
use of the uh fit parameters from
fine fit and non-linear fit to get those
errors
and so one of the things i've really
tried to emphasize
this time is if you're going to compare
theory to experiment
you've got to understand your errors
i see some other questions so i have um
okay i don't know if i've really
answered jose's question
satisfactorily but uh the slides have
been uploaded
uh so they should be under files
and then there's a question from
danielle about
the the dot mb files
you know that lie behind this that
really explain
the labs that you didn't see
so i can i'll go ahead and upload those
to the files later this afternoon
and i'll upload not only the dot mb
files
but i'll upload the video and i'll
try to do that with a sensible directory
structure
so that if you wish to import the video
and play around yourself
you can do that
okay we've got a couple more minutes
before we'll
uh get cut off so if there are any other
questions
um so i see that jeff said something
about
um some of these could be adopted for
high school students
um i certainly think the
helmholtz resonator
could be done well and the simple
harmonic motion labs
i think those could be done by high
school students without a doubt
we have done for our first year students
they normally do an air track experiment
with
pasco sensors i've redone that
using video tracking
which actually produces far superior
data
to the pasco sensors
and there unfortunately we're just going
to have to ship the students the
the video files and have them
work from those because of course right
they don't have air tracks at home
okay okay any other questions
so if there are no other questions then
i'll uh
i guess i'll go ahead and
stop the share and in the meeting